mortar attack chemical
seven survivors yes man
seven total the sheriff just came in can
you get these people to safety I'm gonna
go kill the bastards that did this
you're safe now
promise
the attack came from Jefferson Plaza you
know what to do hey
kill them all
you
Eleni Kelso was one of the first woman
to complete the US Army Ranger school
during training she demonstrated an
aptitude for creative thinking which
made her highly sought after by the CIA
and for a number of years she performed
covert ops as a parent military agent in
the national clandestine service while
working for the CIA she acquired quite a
mixed reputation
particularly with the superiors who
found her methods questionable although
she always got the job done
Kelso was eventually head hunted by the
division and worked as an instructor
before taking on an active agent status
she is cautious and watchful she takes
it all in and assists as a situation
before acting
however when faced with an immediate
threat often a ruthless sight comes out
most likely an effect of
self-preservation and often results in
extreme acts of violence Kelso is one of
the first people we meet in Washington
DC she was one of the few remaining
division agents in the area through our
mission of taking back the capital Kelso
is more released they're helping us out
every step of the way so what is it
about this agent that has people so
suspicious of her
in my opinion there isn't a singular
situation that I could point to in fact
all the way through the story multiple
rig flags should have been raised and
then there were the concerns around his
assessment this particular during the
Jefferson Trade Center mission agents a
task of rescuing agent Espinoza he's
been captured by the hyenas and the
leader Khan Texas fire Espinoza's watch
dating that she's open to a hostage deal
if we back off Kelso tells us to ignore
the deal and go in guns a-blazing and in
turn Espinoza gets killed
she then quickly backtracks stating that
there was nothing we could have done and
hopes the hyena leader suffered before
she died
nothing too major here perhaps it was
just a bad call on her part however
let's now look at the Potomac Events
Center
Luke Olsen's comms get cut off while
she's under heavy fire and eventually
Isaac reports agent down we're led to
believe she's dead and it's not until
the end when she suddenly appears that
we realize she's still alive her story
she states that her watch broke and she
lost comms I don't know just didn't play
out very smoothly in it just all seemed
a bit off speaking of a watch did you
notice you wizard on her belt and the
orange glow just seems a little darker
than normal but even if we ignore these
few situations in every cutscene which
is given some pretty obvious camera
angles close-ups and long pants that
really show that they really want us to
focus on it a lot more than anyone else
a good example of this is when president
Ellis is talking after being rescued
she's barely saying anything but the
camera kept zooming in on her while she
gave some reasonably unimpressed looks
the game is building a personal
connection to Kelso for us potentially
to the point of sitting up and watching
a fall also have you noticed she doesn't
have a static location on the map like
every other NPC why and considering how
invested to us with helping us push out
the hyena outcasts and true sons will
wash you and the black tusk invaded in
fact I don't actually recall hearing
much from her at all
[Music]
Celso is what is known as an a-type
personality she is smart and patient
short-tempered and wears a heart on her
sleeve because of this is relatively
easy to tell that she isn't at all happy
about how things are currently being run
you can also see how frustrated she's
becoming with all the restrictions that
have been placed on her and the team it
was noted in the broken dawn book that
the black tusk can hide an agent who's
gone rogue from being picked up by the
Isaac Network so of that in mind if
she's working with the black tusk it
could explain the way that she acts
about the broad spectrum antivirals the
whole way through the story I mean we
all know they're important but she's
almost a little over the top obsessive
about them even for her she's forever
pushing us to bring back data on the
antivirals and when we do finally bring
everything back to Kelso there's
absolutely no feedback on the notes and
data you gave to her
we did it all Kirk what happened with it
and where was our thank you man as a
freak else Oh God such a dead now but
this could explain where she disappears
all the time and also why we don't
really see or hear from her too much
during the black tusk invasion
if Kelso is truly turned it back on the
sh t it's likely she's ever gone one of
two directions with president Ellis or
the black tusk or maybe she's teamed up
to follow Arin kina I touch base on this
in another video but but think about all
of the messages that Keener's left in DC
they sort of don't really make a lot of
sense he's just repeating himself he
even said himself I don't know why I'm
leaving these messages but if you think
of these messages perhaps not being left
for us to read but for agent Kelso they
start to make a little more sense these
are more of the same type of messages
that he lived for us in New York his way
of trying to lure us over to his way of
thinking and to join his cause think
about it we're unknown to kina with
different agents to the ones he was
dealing with in New York the original
agents of Washington DC have mostly been
killed or of gone missing there are even
reports of agents who have abandoned
their roles as division agents and have
left the city it's unlikely that kina
stop recruiting when he left New York
again this idea speaks as to why she may
have gone dark on the comms from time to
time and why she is so interested and
everything surrounding the
broad-spectrum antivirus but much like
the black tusk I still don't think she's
gone down this path however I do think
she could have been in contact with kina
and potentially the black tusk to
[Music]
along this journey I think with miss
Reid Kelso's Rohrer attitude and dislike
of the traditional rules in law and
order Kelso is relatively emotional yes
but she's under a bit of stress you know
just a little bit all of her fellow
agents have died abandoned the city or
have gone rogue she seems to
legitimately care for the people of the
city and wants to do everything she can
to fix this for them I guess it's not
exactly shocking considering what she's
been through can we do been working with
her as much as you can
activity is mostly painting games that
kind of thing is it helping yeah for
sure but it's a process and triste has a
lot on her plate
maybe if you can stop by sometimes me
the only time that little girl lights up
is when you're around okay yeah sure I
know you're busy I'll make time
I think her unconventional way of
responding to things in the funny look
she gives us more because she just wants
to get the job done she cares more about
the result than the process she will do
whatever it takes however with the
stress of being relatively alone in this
situation hearing so strongly for the
people under her care and watching as
the world around her fall apart
she is beginning and if she made the
right decision in the leave this is the
point in time where Kelso started
looking at her options she isn't going
to up and leave the civilians to to fend
for themselves she'll be looking for the
best and least detrimental way of
gaining peace for the people of DC I
think she has reached up to kena because
she likes the idea of what he wants to
accomplish and that the world is quickly
falling apart but at the same time she
isn't ready to betray the shd and go
full rogue these recordings he lifts are
intended for her to keep reminding her
that he's still there waiting
then again with the invasion of the
black tusk and a goal of creating a new
America perhaps the fastest option of
Curly before the invasion the BTS you
contacted Odessa Sawyer about the
possibility of her coming on board she
turned them down
it wouldn't be unlikely that they also
approached Kelso so she now has a way to
be in contact with them she knows they
are striving to create a new better
world they have all the guns and
financial support the black tasks are
all of a sudden looking like a pretty
good option for bringing peace so there
is the possibility that Kelso has
started or is considering working with
the black tusk but not working for them
she simply wants to do what's best for
the people of DC she fills the division
of fighting a losing battle and she's
looking for outside support personally I
don't think she's gone this far yet but
I think all of this is going through a
head at this stage and she's walking a
fine line and decided which direction
she's going to take with her be with
Keena or the black tusk if things don't
get better I can see her picking a side
down the line
[Music]
I put a crazy amount of research into
this one a lot more than I was expecting
to have to do but on paper there really
isn't too much in relation to each and
Celso I repeated missions over and over
to make sure I hadn't missed anything of
which I'm pretty sure I have so let me
know in the comments below but I'll
admit probably the biggest question I
had that came out of this whole thing
did Kelso either get many the toys he
was after if I can't get more pieces
from the toy store I'm not gonna be able
to finish my [ __ ] math did many get
to finish his map no wonder he seemed so
anxious and stressed all the time
if he made it this far thank you very
much for watching from time to time I
like to get my ramble on with these
theory crafting type videos anyway don't
forget to check out my social media
stuff like Twitter etc I have the links
in the description otherwise thank you
again and I'll catch you in the next one
Cheers
[Music]
[Music]